[Music]
it's rugged let's face it it's rough and rugged
you've got to be able to take it
your body's got to be able to take it
because service means new physical
demands on strength and endurance
that's why in military training you have
to march long distances carry heavy loads
do hard manual labor use your body skillfully
be ready for instant action
withstand strains and tensions
live under all conditions be prepared for anything
and everything are you ready physically for this
training well when you enter service ready or
not the physical training begins immediately
and it will go on every day it's going to be
rough and rugged training to toughen you up
if you aren't ready for it you're going to
have more than your share of sore muscles
aching feet poor endurance exhaustion strain
and awkwardness yes it can be tough for you if you
aren't ready physically it can be a lot easier for
you if you are and if you are ready later it may
mean the difference between failure and success
it may even mean saving a life yours or a buddies
getting ready physically means beginning
right now while you're still in school
to get in condition how do you go about it first
consider how much time you have to get ready
a freshman has a good four years he can plan a
fairly extensive program for himself the same for
a sophomore he has a good stretch of time to get
in shape a junior has some time but not too much
he has to work a little harder than the others
a senior doesn't have much time to get ready but
it can be done if each man takes personal
responsibility for his physical condition
the next step is a complete health examination
and we mean complete don't be satisfied with
just a quick checkup eyes ears nose throat
posture reflexes abdominal organs skin
feet these are some of the most important
things to have checked above all your heart
and lungs need examination have your chest
x-rayed find out for sure about your health
don't forget your teeth have them examined
check up on your health and be ready to correct
any health problems you have the third step in
your program is to check your physical ability
to help you do this a set of physical achievement
standards has been prepared by the armed forces
committee of the american association for
health physical education and recreation
their minimum standards that help you check
your physical condition think how well you
would do now on the tests here's one of them
climb a 15-foot rope in 20 seconds or less
here's another do six or more dips on the
parallel bars can you do six or more chins
at least 45 sit-ups
broad jump seven feet or more
run 300 yards in 42 seconds
throw a softball 175 feet
float for at least two minutes
swim 40 yards or more
step off a 10-foot platform with your clothes on
find out how you measure up to these standards
and you'll have a good idea of your present
physical ability now you know how much time
you have you know what your general health
is you know what your physical ability is
you're all ready to plan and work for improvement
have any defects corrected that showed up in your
general health exam if you have them taken care of
now they won't become big troubles in the future
then work with your physical education teacher
to plan your program of physical development
keep in mind you need to
include ways to build strength
strength that will be useful in many service jobs